we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemail caller asks a question i asked
on twitter a few days ago what if the
armed coronavirus protesters were groups
of black people would it be different
how they were handled take a listen to
the voicemail question hi Dave my
question is when protesters are blocking
er entrances for asking nurses and
bringing rifles on state capitol grounds
where are the police
right if black people or any other group
did the same exact thing carrying guns
the police would be there in riot gear
arresting people but if you carry an
American flag in your white you can walk
anyplace you want with a rifle that's my
question thanks yeah
I am presenting the question without
comment check out my tweet about it see
what the reactions were and I want to
hear from you what if indeed the lion's
share of the lockdown protesters showing
up with long guns and I think some of
them even like bulletproof vest what if
they were mostly black folks how would
this this be covered in media how would
police react let me know what you think
we have a fantastic bonus show today we
will talk about risks of additional
starvation as a result of the Coronis
about coronavirus pandemic on the bonus
show and much more get instant access by
signing up at join pakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show